well you know the good news though is
that uh warner brothers has submitted
a wonder woman 1984 for consideration
for 15 academy awards including best
pictures so
we'll see how that works out uh
apparently
i've never watched either wonder woman
movie apparently everyone hated this
latest wonder woman movie i guess it's
it's
they don't like it uh but they like the
first one
i i don't know it's just for me
you shouldn't be surprised when a movie
called wonder woman isn't good
it's it's a it's a right it's she she
flies in an invisible jet
and she has a magic lasso am i getting
this right
and her name is wonder woman and you
expected it to not be horrible
is that what you expected and you know
of course the
the unspoken truth here that that nobody
wants to say is that really
all female superhero movies are terrible
i mean they all really are
uh no no i'm not saying they have to be
i'm not saying it's impossible to make a
female superhero movie that's good it's
just
they haven't done it yet and part of the
problem is that
so often you know it's it's they're so
they want us to be so impressed with the
fact that it
is a female superhero and so that's
they're just driving that message home
the girl power thing no just make an
interesting superhero movie
and the superhero happens to be a woman
that's the way it should be
you don't need to beat us over the head
with the girl power stuff every second
that's what they do
and um that's why the movie is isn't any
good in case you're wondering why wonder
woman isn't good it's because again it's
it's wonderful what were you expecting
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matte wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content